[Musica]
eccoci salve a tutti io oggi vi racconto
la storia la storia di un ragazzo che a
16 anni decide che voleva fare impresa
la mia storia personale che è fatta da
tempo la fatica da trasformare quelle
che erano considerate cose impossibili
in cose possibili
è una storia e perseveranza che ha
seguito una visione e che ed è riuscita
a arrivare a compimento grazie alle
connessioni alle contaminazioni che sono
riuscito a coinvolgere lungo il mio
percorso
io già 16 anni mi guardavo avanti
guardava avanti la mia vita guardavo la
mia vita 30 anni oggi ne o 32 e
cominciamo a pensare che volevo creare
qualcosa di mio
creare qualcosa di rivoluzionario ma a
16 anni la spensieratezza dell'età
ovviamente non mi portava non avevo
nemmeno l'esperienza a quell'età per
capire dove in quale settore cosa volevo
fare però già sapevo
dentro di me che non avrei lasciato agli
altri decidere cosa fare nella mia vita
sono stato anche bocciato secondo
secondo anno del liceo non ho detto
prima vera ma sono stato bocciato
ugualmente e il percorso di studi è solo
un percorso di sui travagliato perché è
perché guardavo sempre chi mi dava
indicazioni con con remore non non
volevo che qualcuno mi indicasse cosa
fare poi arrivato il momento
dell'università che è il momento più
difficile per un ragazzo perché il
momento in cui devi decidere realmente
cosa fare nella tua vita e io ancora non
avevo deciso prima facoltà ingegneria
gestionale alla prima al primo esame in
itinere di analisi 1 matematica 1 il
professore entra in aula con una
maglietta con scritto minimo 7 il mio
collega di università e chiede al
professore cosa vuol dire minimo 7
minimo 7 volte prima di passare
io li ho preso il mio zaino o chiusi
liberi o scappato via dall università
sono tornato a casa ma dico a mia madre
mamma cambio facoltà e magari
giustamente dice perché perdo troppo
tempo ingegneria gestionale perderei
troppo tempo io non volevo perdere tempo
allora ho deciso di iscrivermi in giù di
speranza dai primi sei esami è un certo
punto faccio una riflessione conto gli
anni prima di arrivare nel mondo del
lavoro e capisco che non avrei
guadagnato un euro da giurisprudenza
prima dei 28 anni sino a 28 anni non
sarei stato con una stabilità economica
devo stare ancora dietro a mamma e papà
ed è quello che io non voler nuovamente
gli scappa scappa università e questa
volta dico i miei io voglio lavorare io
voglio fare impresa mio padre aveva una
piccola impresa di costruzioni
ferroviarie manutenzione e costruzione
di linee ferroviarie e qui mi chiedo a
lui di andare a lavorare con lui ma non
immaginatevi che mi ha dato una
scrivania o un posto a stella dietro un
ufficio caldo comodo mi ha dato guanti
scarpe antinfortunistica caschetto tuta
da cantiere e mi ha spedito mille
chilometri a casa mia
busto arsizio in un cantiere
io ho fatto l'operaio per dai 19 ai 25
anni
il mio pieno un ruolo in cantiere era
luglio c'erano trenta gradi all'ombra
il mio ruolo era a saldare le rotaie
1800 gradi saldature alluminio termiche
fusione di acciaio i miei mi girano in
vacanza io solo lavoro tailleur oggi
ringrazio mio padre perché mi han dato
la possibilità di imparare un mestiere
di fare un'esperienza che mi ha portato
in un contesto totalmente nuovo
sconosciuto
per me che era il mondo del cantiere
stare a contatto con persone totalmente
differenti da me con una differenza di
età fino ai 26 anni quando decido che
volevo creare qualcosa per me la fase
della vita fondamentale di un uomo in
una donna in cui si pongono le basi
della vita siano dai 16 ai 25 poi dai 25
comincia il la lancetta comincia a fare
scattare il tempo della maturità e
quindi ho già 26 anni mi sentivo già
vecchio e chiamavo ancora creato
qualcosa di mio poi un giorno
l'illuminazione
l'idea di rivoluzionare un settore il
settore delle traverse ferroviarie le
traverse ferroviarie sono quelle
strutture che compongono i binari
anticamente era in legno oggi lo
standard è costituito alle traversine in
calcestruzzo ancora per poco considerate
queste strutture in calcestruzzo sono
state ingegnerizzate nel 1900
noi oggi andiamo sui treni su una
struttura una sovrastruttura ferroviaria
ingegnerizzato nei primi del novecento
questa struttura e creano alti costi di
manutenzione e io capisco che c'era un
gap in questo mercato
guardava quelli che erano i mega trend
del settore la green economy la sirco
dell'economia riciclo di materie prime
quindi le materie prime seconde creare
prodotti in grado di dare un futuro
sostenibile alla collettività e da li
metto in modo la mia start up non ero
ingegnere cerco le competenze
cerco le competenze mi
affianco a un industrial designer che
insieme a me a progetta la traversa
green ray nel 2012 costituisco la mia
start up in un momento in cui di start
up non se ne parlava
io dico sempre non ho costituito una
start up ho voluto costituire un'azienda
ma tutto quello che vedete qui io lo
traduco anche in fortuna aver avuto la
visione di mettere sul mercato un
prodotto giusto nel momento giusto nel
momento storico giusto oggi che i
livelli e brevettate in 80 paesi nel
mondo
è un prodotto ingegnerizzato vi forniamo
vari paesi nel mondo e ha 32 anni e oggi
sono a capo di un team che è in forte
crescita
e tutto questo è stato possibile grazie
alla visione che ho avuto quando avevo
16 anni cioè quella di dire io nella mia
vita voglio lasciare il segno
io nella mia vita non volevo valere
soltanto i due euro del mio corpo come
diceva lorenzo allora cosa ho fatto ho
cercato le migliori competenze sono
partito sono andato fuori alla sicilia
mi sono trasferito a milano è la mia
start up stata incubata ho avuto la
fortuna di riuscire a cominciare il
politecnico di milano a supportarci
perché il politico di milano perché era
il quinto centro di ricerca migliore in
europa nel settore ferroviario
come ho creato la connessione l'ho
voluta e l'ho creata io ho scritto a
cinque centri universitari una mail mi
hanno risposto solamente in tre ma non
il politecnico che era quello che volevo
non mi sono abbattuto
ho preso un volo sono andato lì ho
bussato alla porta
siamo presentato io ho cercato di
convincerli
li ho convinti oggi noi siamo fra le
start up di punta del politecnico milano
ho cominciato a partecipare a tutte
quelle che erano le competition per
start up
io prima non riuscivo a stare su un
palco ho fatto anche l'animatore
turistico nei villaggi come istruttore
di vela e la prima volta che mi hanno
detto di salire su un palco l'ho già
pronta la valigia per andare via però
dovuto imparare anche a comunicare
l'idea la comunicazione delle idee è la
base per renderle credibili e negli anni
in cui il prodotto ancora non esisteva
era soltanto una bella idea
comincio a vincere competition per start
up si comincia a parlare di gènèrale
dire rail vai sui giornali cominciamo a
vincere premi anche premi economici fino
a un giorno in cui il mondo mi crolla
addosso
dovevamo sviluppare la miscela in
plastica e gomma riciclata per
realizzare il nostro prodotto
gli esperti chimici quando i presenti
l'idea mi dicono impossibile eravamo nel
il brevetto era già depositato in 148
paesi
avevo vinto premi per startup avevo
vinto premi economici e mi sento dire
dagli esperti impossibile
l'iran le scelte erano due mollare e non
sarei qui a raccontarvi questa storia
perseverare
ho avuto il coraggio di decidere di
investire e ho detto loro
i fondi sono i nostri dimostratemi che
questo è impossibile
dopo aver testato più di trenta michelle
e il risultato è che oggi noi abbiamo
creato una miscela composita da plastica
da rifiuto urbano e gomma da pneumatici
fuori uso
unica al mondo perché l'unica in grado
di essere stampata iniezione che un
processo industriale abbastanza
particolare questo ve lo racconto perché
molte volte nei progetti che hanno
successo i progetti che che poi arrivano
sul mercato e che cominciano a fatturare
si conosce soltanto una parte la parte
quella della comunicazione quella che va
sui giornali
quella bella ma non è per niente mai un
percorso facile creare innovazione
creare innovazione soprattutto in dei
settori industriali che sono altamente
chiusi all'innovazione pensata al mondo
ferroviario
gli ho detto prima dai primi del 900 ci
sono quelle strutture e quindi un mondo
dove convincere sull'innovazione e
difficoltoso e farlo da startup farlo da
aziende piccole e ancora più
difficoltoso però tutto questo è stato
possibile grazie alla contaminazione che
sulla nostra storia è avvenuta le
connessioni noi oggi abbiamo creato una
rete relazioni con centri di ricerca
partner industriali che hanno avuto
l'intuizione e la visione di credere
in quella idea folle di un ragazzo e che
sono riusciti insieme a noi oggi a
creare qualcosa di assolutamente this
ratti dirompente
noi oggi ci troviamo in una fase di
overbooking green ray oggi è conosciuta
dall'australia agli stati uniti dal nord
europa al sud africa insieme una
situazione in cui non riusciamo a dar
seguito a tutte le richieste che
arrivano dal mondo però quello che
voglio lasciarvi oggi è un messaggio non
è impossibile possibile per tutti fare
questo quando io mi ritrovo in questi
contesti mi sento quasi trattato come un
uomo straordinario
non sono per niente straordinario o
soltanto creduto nella mia idea ho
convinto le persone sulla mia idea ho
dimostrato che l'idea era possibile e
tutto questo si è tradotto in un
successo oggi ha 32 anni posso dire che
16 anni fa quando ero sul mio destino e
immaginavo la mia vita a 30 anni posso
dirgli avercela fatta
e quando parlo a un pubblico e giovani a
delle persone che mi guardano come
esempio dico solamente che tutti quanti
sono in grado di farcela
grazie
[Applauso]